research shows we hear anywhere from get
this 10 to 200 lives per day everything
from little white lies to more serious
untruths vanessa van edwards has spent
more than a decade studying human
behavior and she says if you want to
know whether someone is being dishonest
pay close attention to their body
language she's the author of the q's
master of the secret language of
charismatic communication vanessa van
edwards joins us now good morning to you
good morning and it is a good morning to
see you yes um this is something that
and i'm i'm i'm being very honest i see
it i feel the honesty i see my body yes
it looks so good thank you thank you um
i want to get straight to the lip purse
because that's a big one you said that
people will do this
before they tell this lie so explain so
we have to understand liars don't like
to lie we know that lying gets us into
trouble so what you'll see often is
right before someone lies they withhold
so a lip purse if you press your lips
together
it's as if we're saying hold it together
keep it in don't get in trouble so right
before a lie like ask a woman how much
do you weigh and she'll go um
because she's trying to hold it in i'm
never going to ask that question
let's start there let's start with that
etiquette right you also have to
remember that there's no pinocchio's
nose there's no one cue that shows
someone's lying what we're looking for
is patterns of deceit and research has
found that there are certain red flags
that are common the lip purse is a
really good one to look out for no
pinocchio's nose however the nose can be
a tell very much i think that the writer
had an inkling so research this is
ridiculous research but it found that we
have tissue in our nose okay that swells
when we lie we use thermal imaging
cameras
meaning so next time you lie not that
you ever do not that you ever did next
time pay attention as if your nose
itches they found that liars will often
touch their nose
researchers analyzed bill clinton's
testimony during the monica lewinsky
trial and they found that in his lying
testimony he touched his nose 26 times
in his honest testimony he didn't touch
his nose at all so watch out for well
that is suddenly wild
that's interesting but how do you know
too it's not allergies allergies well no
not allergies
they control for allergies right or a
little bit of anxiety okay so this is
what's really important is we're looking
for clusters right so like if someone's
it's out of season or someone just got
like a swab yes they're gonna be itching
their nose you're looking for sudden
changes in behavior or
incongruency so for example we're
looking for when the body doesn't match
the words one of my favorite line cues
is a mismatched nod this works really
well when someone says yes but shakes
their head wow or says no but
shakespeare yes so for example you could
say so um you know do you like the new
colleague um
yeah
yeah she's great right that's a mismatch
and that's we're very odd that we
mismatch our verbal uh you i read that
first person pronouns can be a tell for
lying first remind us what a first
person pronoun is okay
i'm your mai so this is another
psychology of behavior is that we don't
like to lie we don't want to get
implicated in it right so you'll notice
that without realizing it subconsciously
we drop the i me or my someone will say
oh uh that email must have gone to spam
or didn't get that email instead of oh i
didn't get that you know
um yeah running late not i'm running
late and that's because we're trying to
distance ourselves from that thing
that's going to get us trouble in emails
if you notice a sudden drop and i near
my
pay attention a little red flag a little
red flag dating profiles little red flag
what about when you're talking to
somebody and they look away and you're
like what are you looking at we
automatically assume make eye contact
they're lying because i i look away a
lot i realize like when i'm doing
interviews and i'll look of course
thinking about what i'm going to say if
you look up to the left you're lying i
don't know how this got out there let's
bust this name from a movie i think it's
from a movie so
everyone seems to think that shifty eyes
or looking up to the left means you're
lying actually research has found liars
look you in the eye more
why they want to know do you believe me
do you believe me do you believe me so
looking up is a processing behavior if
someone's remembering something if i
asked you to do math you'd look up so
that's a myth we don't shifty eyes does
not mean it is deception
wow
and this helps us as a whole when we can
identify people who are lying i think it
is an essential skill also we did a
little research study we had people play
two truths and a lie have you ever
played this game yeah okay so here was
the big one that we found on the lie
people use the question inflection and
that's because liars don't believe what
they're saying so they're asking do you
believe me so i would say i'm from
austin i love dogs i'm a vegetarian
vanessa is that american
more effectively vanessa man edwards
thank you so much this was awesome we
could talk all morning all day